hey how are you doing
hi good morning you
i'm doing well so listen i know you've
had some time to think about you know
everything that happened last night so
how are you feeling with how everything
went down
um
you know i definitely wish i would have
stayed in the house obviously i
genuinely thought i had strong enough
personal connections to get the votes
but i just think that uh
you know i i feel good i feel all right
about it it's all good it's all good i
think they just saw an opportunity to
take out a threat mate and they don't
get it
yeah it's like do you feel like it has
sunk in
uh we're working on that yeah
we're working on that
um you know when the power of veto was
used on josh what was going through your
head right before you were nominated
instantly when kevin said he's going to
use the power veto i just started
smiling because i knew it was either
me moose or geno
i think the shot gino would have been a
shot at the showmance i think me and
moose uh were interchangeable in that
position so
um i figured something's some spicy was
on the horizon
yeah uh you know in your speech to the
house guest you called out the hoh marty
in front of everyone what would you say
was your intention with the statement
that you made
i basically wanted to make an enemy of
almost half the house
um to make the other half that i needed
votes from feel secure with keeping me
in the house because i would then always
be a bigger target
than they would um and that was that was
kind of my plan and i wanted them to
also know that i definitely wasn't
shooting in their direction
um a vote for me was a vote of loyalty
and i and i wanted them that
yeah um you know you were voted out by
unanimous vote did you have the heads up
at all before this eviction
um i had a pretty good idea that it was
going that direction yeah um but hey i
was fighting to last minute i think they
just you know finally were like
you know i don't know if we're gonna get
you on this side of the block um again
and without a chance to play in pov
so i think they just like we can't we
can't take we can't miss on this shot so
yeah um in marty's farewell message to
you he said he hopes he could be friends
for life do you see a friendship with
marty in the future
oh sorry i just that's natural um
absolutely not
absolutely not uh absolutely not like
what listen i'm not i'm not a bitter
person but like damn like you can't just
backstab your boy twice and then come
through and lie to me all week and thank
you
and then backstab me and then be like so
do you want to go for coffee absolutely
not absolutely not i want to go for
coffee sorry
um yeah so no
okay so now
um you know as as you were as you were
leaving um you said you wanted to be
remembered as the prank
champ so what do you think is the best
prank that you pulled off
oh man i used to scare everybody
everywhere every time so like
one of the ones i did too was i was just
sitting in the toilet area like the
bathroom and i waited for betty to open
the door
early in the morning betty's barely got
one eye open and i was like i bet he
just lost it once i bet he was crawling
on the floor trying to scare the people
in the shower and i
scared her i saw her coming through and
i just hit her and she went like
like stand up like this it was funny so
oh and but i mean the one the one that i
didn't uh tell moose about was that i
put a full flank of salmon
in moose's bag and i tucked it in the
side pocket so when i was leaving i said
moose there's you're gonna smell
something fishy
and i'm hoping he can pick up on the
salmon at some point but
who knows oh my god that is a strong
smell
yeah it's gonna be stanky stink yeah
all right so let's talk about this you
were the first member of the jury on big
brother canada's season 10. how are you
feeling about that
uh i mean shoot i wish i would have won
but you know i'll uh you know for me i
really do feel like i got the full big
brother canada you know experience and
i'm you know experiencing it as we as we
speak but um you know winning veto
winning the first hoh i mean put my name
in the books like pull myself off the
block be nominated to be back door to
campaign and each slop and then the last
thing was jury and it was just the
cherry on top so yeah
do you have a strategy going into jury
at all
um
yeah
uh i don't know i'm just i'm always
trying to make sure i keep an open mind
i always made logical decisions in a
house um
and you know i want to carry that into
the jury house i'm not a bitter jury
member so like i might seem better right
now but uh
give me like i don't know 24 48 hours
i'll be good yeah yeah it's got to sink
in a little bit more listen that's
understandable um
you know who would you like to see
walking through the jury doors next
um m-a-r-t-y
how do you think that's gonna go down
i think it might be an uncomfortable
week for me but hey i'd rather him uh
walk through the house tonight well
basically i think the majority of the
house wants to take their shot i think
marty can't play this week so you know i
think that
that
it would just be maybe a backdoor
situation something like that i don't
know we can only hope right
you know when you you think of your time
in the house uh and i'm sure you're
gonna think more about this as the days
go on but who do you think is truly
pulling the strings in the house
i think summer has a big influence in
the house behind the scenes
um never has to win
is in
really good graces with betty and josh
um
i don't know if moose necessarily uh
trust her but you know i think it's in
good grace is there it's in marty's
pocket there convinced kevin to use i
think had something to do with them
using the veto i think summer's like you
know it was a big part of kyle going up
on as a backdoor i think summer really
has an influence in the game but hasn't
had to go out and win
power to do it
so
yeah that's good it's a that's a good
perspective it's an interesting
perspective um listen i know this uh
season has been wild i feel like we say
that with every season but this season
really has been a bit of a roller
coaster of emotions of course everyone
involved how would you sum up this
experience in one word
let's go with bonkers
let's go with bonkers you know or uh or
unpredictable but let's go bonkers i
like that one bonkers is a good word
um
are you uh with this experience
you know you always have an idea of how
things are going to go and then when you
get in it
you know it's a whole other story is
this journey how you thought it was
going to go
it was
it was
a little bit harder than i thought i
think um yeah it was a little bit harder
than i thought i think the comps for me
i thought i could do better in the hohs
like
they just i don't know the trivia killed
me i just like i mean i didn't know the
price of a teddy bear i missed spicy
bee's door like little things like that
you know but um yeah it was harder than
i thought the hohs were harder than i
thought i thought i was just gonna crush
them back to back for one you know one
week after another but
yeah that's what i would say
listen uh
so much more to go when it comes to this
show thank you so much for your time
it's really nice talking to you
thanks appreciate morgan thank you
you